[Music]
you'll hear people say that david icke
he thinks the world's controlled by
lizards and that's as far as it freakin
goes human race get off your knees what
are you doing down there mainstream
media it needs to keep the dots apart if
you only see dots you don't see the
picture you connect the dots what's
happening becomes perfectly blatantly
obvious when you look at my life in the
last nearly 30 years where I went
through levels of ridicule public
national ridicule incessant and I'm
sitting here now and I talk to thousands
of people all over the world unless you
are to put your bloody self where your
mouth is
I couldn't have chosen to walk away
because I'm hurt I chose not to be and
thus I've done what I'm done and I'm
doing what I'm doing
my life as a kid was playing football
and watching steam trains and I decided
that I wanted to be a professional
footballer and I thought that's what my
life was going to be and then six months
after I joined Coventry my left knee
swelled up for no reason and they
eventually told me probably rheumatoid
arthritis and that was the end of my
football career then thought you can sit
down and you can feel sorry for yourself
or you can get up and get on with it and
so I moved on and moved on and
eventually ended up at the BBC Sport and
then I got involved in the Green Party
this was another kind of extraordinary
series of ridiculous coincidences the
moment happened just down the seafront
here that was the start of the
transformation of my life in the most
extraordinary way
one day something happened here I walk
in and then it wasn't a voice but it was
a very strong thought form just said to
me I went through my mind go and look at
the books on the far side and I got over
there and in among the romantic novels
was one book was very different had a
woman's face on the front and it was
called mine to mine by a psychic called
Betty Shan so I read the book in 24
hours arranged to see her the third time
I went on this medical type venture
she's doing the hands-on healing and she
then says that she was seeing a figures
in her mind and that they were wanting
her to communicate to me from them and
then as I'm told and I'm gonna go out on
a world stage and reveal great secrets
that there was a story that had to be
told I started to see what was really
happening and that's when this
synchronistic a coincidence sequence
really kicked in right in the middle of
that I went on the wagon show that's
when I was first introduced to absolute
historic levels of ridicule but then as
the years passed people were getting
more and more wary about the world you
know what is going on they were getting
more and more if you like cynical they
started to look more and more towards my
work and this has gone on and gone on
and now I walk around and people are
stopping me want to talk about the
information we should be celebrating
diversity diversity is an expression of
all possibility we need to start being
at peace with other people having
different views and expressing different
lifestyles than we do
[Applause]
I'm coming up to 66 I ain't going yet
I've got too much to do this world is
nothing not even a smear like what we
were told it is if you want to keep
people in ignorance of what is going on
you have to control their perceptions
perception is everything
this agenda for the world doesn't happen
within the period in office of a prime
minister or president it's not those
people that are making the decisions
it's this network that he's always there
no matter who's in power this
catastrophe in the Middle East that's
taken the lives and maimed untold
millions of people has been coldly
calculated from the start
that's the psychopathic no empathy
mentality that I'm talking about that is
running this world that's what we're
dealing with it's a state of awareness
and yes it does take expression through
a reptilian form in in the shadows in
the hidden but it also takes expression
through through humans too and they're
the ones running the world kind of makes
sense of the world a bit doesn't it
the moon is actually a command center
for extraterrestrial groups including
reptilians this reptilian race feeds off
human energy it feeds off human low
vibrational emotion and there's a
particular energy of children before
they reach puberty that it wants so they
put the children through a ritual that
builds up the terror
and then they kill the child they drink
the blood because there's a certain
adrenaline that goes into the bladder
from the terror which is a like a nectar
to them it's when you start to realize
that that your mind starts to open to
the fact that we're clearly not alone
it's a crazy crazy world but why why is
it an upside-down lunatic world that we
live in this is the force that is
pushing Society in a particular
direction of more and more
centralization of control more and more
imposition through the police state and
that's what we call the elite that's
what we call the 1% and it's what
increasingly has been called the deep
state the mainstream media is dismissing
anyone that's exposing the truth you
know what they never asked or never
check is it true
well hold on a minute this guy's saying
this let's check it out let's see what
evidence he's got well there's no
evidence is there but the biggest group
of people who are responsible for what
is happening are those it is happening -
but what they've also done which is the
kicker and the killer is they've then
insisted that everyone else accept the
program they've accepted and don't
question it otherwise they're mad or
ridiculed or crazy or dangerous people
have no idea of the power we have to
dictate our own lives
not that I'm a special person I'm just
doing what I do because I feel it's
right is there a part of you that sort
of wishes that hadn't happened to you
know you could offer me 50 million
pounds and say oh you can have 50
million pounds when you were still
working at the BBC then you could do
whatever you like with your life and and
none of this that has happened was
having none of the ridicule none of the
none of the abuse none of it and you can
have that I'd say nothing because I
wouldn't change anything that has
happened in my life I wouldn't change
what I do I have a simple philosophy on
life so simple do what you like so long
as you don't impose it on others dead
simple that's it
how come that guy who we left in the
gutter being laughed at by passers-by
and we thought it was over
that's him done how is he doing what
he's doing now it's because I chose to
create that reality because I have the
power to do it so do you so does
everybody the system wants us to believe
we don't the people we see running the
world in the politicians the bankers and
all these people why would anyone but a
psychopath create a financial system
which lends people money that doesn't
exist called credit and if they can't
pay it back it takes away their home and
throws them in the street only
psychopaths could do that that's the
mentality that's running the world and
we need to take it back because they've
been in control for far too long
[Music]
I move seamlessly between conspiracy and
reality concepts to you know how do you
think man you know I'll get on tomorrow
I'm also living in the world as it is
you know like a cup of tea I like a
glass of wine i watch a bit of football
al I love watching you know dramas life
is not one thing it's anything you want
it to be beep beep beep
[Music]
you